un petit préambule avant de parler des
travaux on parle beaucoup de
discrimination
on parle de discrimination positive
juste pour rappeler qu'en anglais on
parle d'affin d'affirmative action c'est
pas du tout la même perception la
discrimination positive le terme
discrimination serait peut-être à
enlever de ce point-là en santé on parle
d'équité pour plein de raisons et ça
c'est acté en tout cas par tous les
personnes qui œuvrent dans la santé et
qui travaillent sur la santé de la femme
en décembre dernier on a organisé des
États généraux des femmes de santé où il
y avait plusieurs centaines de personnes
les États généraux chez nous ont comme
objectif de trouver des solutions utiles
pratiques et concrètes à de grands
enjeux de santé et cette année le thème
choisi était la santé de la femme
l'année dernière je ne résiste pas au
fait de vous le dire c'était la place de
la femme dans le secteur professionnel
de la santé vous imaginez qu'on a trouvé
énormément de solutions qu'on a
identifié énormément d'enjeux je vous en
parle quand vous voulez
un petit rappel méthodologique sur ces
états généraux d'abord on fait une revue
de la littérature grise française c'est
à dire les études qui sont qui ont été
publiées qu'on peut trouver en ligne
on en extrait les problématiques qui
existent on les présente aux femmes de
santé et les femmes de santé
identifiées avec nous des grands enjeux
sur lesquels elles veulent travailler
qui répondent au panorama qu'on leur a
fait à cette synthèse de la revue de la
littérature 14 ateliers collaboratifs
ont été créés l'événement a eu lieu le 9
décembre 30 solutions ont été proposées
et données au cabinet ministériel de la
santé de l'égalité de la fonction
publique et une lettre ouverte au
pouvoir public signé par 700 personnes a
été écrite pour créer un institut
national santé de la femme qui serait
publique privée à but lucratif et privé
à but non lucratif on est en train de
s'accrocher pour trouver la structure
juridique qu'il porte qui aurait comme
objectif de porter une stratégie
nationale santé de la femme qui n'existe
pas
et ça nous a paru absolument incroyable
que ça n'existe pas
à noter aussi il n'existe pas de
parcours de santé de la femme en dehors
de la maternité du cancer du col et du
cancer du sein il y en a pas on parle de
parcours de santé parcours de santé
c'est la prévention le soin le poste
soin c'est l'ensemble de ce qui concerne
la santé de la femme alors on l'a
travaillé ce le jour des États généraux
je vous en parlerai une autre fois
éventuellement mais à titre d'exemple
concrets saviez-vous que les petites
filles sont traitées plusieurs années
après les petits garçons quand elles ont
un retard de croissance
de croissance
et on sait qu'il est important de donner
les hormones croissant son beau moment
ça c'est un exemple tout à fait concret
de ce qui se passe actuellement à la
santé on n'avait pas du tout du tout du
tout perçu ça avant de faire cette étude
de la sainte revue de la littérature pas
du tout on avait des échos et les femmes
de santé nous demander de travailler
dessus et on s'était pas posé la
question du tout et on a découvert qu'il
y avait tellement de trous dans la
raquette il y avait tellement
d'inégalités il y avait tellement de
choses qui n'avaient pas été faites
qu'on n'a pas été capable de dire mais
sur quel sujet on va travailler et du
coup on a organisé un atelier qui avait
comme objectif de réfléchir à quel sujet
on allait travailler dans ces états
généraux
le thème des États généraux précis et
inégalités de santé chez les femmes
brisées les paradigmes mais proposer une
approche positive vous allez comprendre
pourquoi très vite ce qui est ressorti
de cette synthèse que je peux vous
envoyer
c'est que si on n'a pas compris que tout
tourne autour de la charge mentale des
femmes du sexisme intégré des tabous et
des biaisés alors on n'a pas du tout
compris ce qui se passe dans la santé de
la femme
et c'est ça qu'on a identifié et on a pu
démontrer par les études que la charge
mentale est responsable 1 de l'accès aux
soins et de l'accès à la prévention or
si on parle de prévention des
préventions tous qu'on propose je viens
de PES juste pour préciser donc je suis
une fan de prévention et pendant des
années je me suis moi la première fois
voyez tout ce que nous proposons en
prévention notamment pour les femmes
alourdies la charge mentale donc elles
ne vont pas dans la prévention puisqu'on
leur propose une prévention qui est à
l'origine alourdine à charge mentale et
donc on tourne en rond en fait dans ce
circuit de prévention et c'est ça qu'on
a découvert on a découvert ça pourquoi
parce qu'il y a ne serait-ce que 3 ans
même si de 85 l'idée on parlait à peine
de charge mentale encore moins de charge
mentale dite médicale maintenant qui est
en gros que la femme si elle a une
famille va penser au rendez-vous de tout
le monde sauf des siens et donc elle va
pas aller faire ses dépistages et autres
d'autant plus qu'en plus derrière on
parle de s'ils sont dépistage est
positif et qu'elle a un cancer on va
parler de cancer évitable car vous
pouvez dépister tôt vous imaginez quoi
de la culpabilité des femmes d'avoir un
cancer évitable parce qu'elle est pas
allé se faire dépister à temps donc
voilà donc ça c'est juste un peu qui se
passe un peu dans et c'est ce qu'on a
trouvé donc je vais avancer un peu les
freins donc à cette prise en charge en
fait d'être bien soigné ou de prendre
soin de sa santé sont en deuxième
exposition à charge mentale en première
l'argent
l'argent et on sait que les femmes sont
plus précaires etc etc donc je reviens
pas sur ces démonstrations là donc ce
sont les deux points on s'est retrouvés
face à ça avec cette notion de tabou qui
revenait toujours en fond toujours et
encore avec cette notion de banalisation
des symptômes avec cette notion de
maladie totalement inconnue de tous avec
cette notion de maladie mixte mais qui
ont des spécificités féminines et on
s'est dit mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait
qu'est-ce qu'on fait de ça on a décidé
de travailler en amont des États
généraux sur deux grands ateliers faire
en sorte que les préventions les
préventions primaires secondaires et
tertiaires ne soient pas perçue comme
des contraintes supplémentaires mais un
moyen de lever la charge mentale des
femmes quelque chose qui n'a jamais été
fait dans la santé jamais été pensé
comme ça on s'est dit objectivement on
va dire voilà on entre femmes qu'on
était un peu folle de partir là-dessus
qu'on y arriverait jamais et pourtant on
l'a fait et le deuxième point c'est la
littératie en santé ou comment donner la
bonne info le bon choix au bon moment
d'autres termes comment les tabous
autour de la femme la charge mentale je
vais en venir à l'enjeu du travail
30 solutions donc et je vais vous en
citer quelques-unes en préalable juste
la charge mentale la grande confusion
entre la charge mentale et la santé
mentale on l'a eu on l'a eu pour plein
de raisons et donc on parlait parfois de
santé mentale parfois de charge mentale
les deux sont intimement liés en fait et
covid pour ne pas le citer puisque vous
nous posez la question à démontrer et on
le sait et à alourdi en fait à alourdi
la charge mentale des femmes mais a
aussi indirectement puisque on a vu déjà
dans les dans les les discours tout à
l'heure qu'il y avait une une différence
entre les hommes et les femmes qui a été
montré dans une étude notamment une
étude Suisse que on n'avait pas du tout
la même façon de percevoir
nos risques le traitement et
l'interprétation du stress n'est pas la
même là je parle d'études voilà
les convictions de pouvoir maîtriser son
son existence elle est moins marquée
cette conviction chez les femmes
et en plus on ajoute à ça de plus faible
revenu donc c'est compliqué plus pour
les femmes que pour les hommes c'est
comme ça et la perte de l'identité du
rôle sexuel on en parle trop peu
l'infertilité la ménopause les
expériences d'avortement tout ça font
que en fait on a plus de vulnérabilités
à ce niveau là et donc si on ajoute à ça
la charge mentale et ben là on passe du
côté santé mentale donc c'est toute cet
enjeu donc on ne peut pas faire fille de
la charge mentale en santé publique en
fait mais jusqu'à présent rien rien rien
n'a été pris en compte en santé publique
dans les dispositifs de prévention
concernant la charge mentale à part sans
doute pour la médecine travail où vous
en tenez compte mais dans le quotidien
et dans l'ensemble des politiques
publiques la charge mentale elle passe à
lasse il n'y a pas un seul indicateur de
charge mentale dans tous les dispositifs
qu'on propose
du coup on a fait plusieurs
recommandations je vous cite au niveau
de la charge mentale recommenciation qui
concerne les employeurs donc nous allons
dans le milieu de travail et je vais
parler et pardon la médecine du travail
donc je suis très heureuse de vous
rencontrer mesdames parce qu'on a des
choses à discuter
nous proposons que les préventions
soient mises en place sur le temps de
travail voire organisé par les
employeurs
et tous les employeurs qui ont été aux
États généraux étaient d'accord et
certains le font déjà certains ont une
journée de congés dédiée à la prévention
voilà comme ça au moins c'est clair
c'est cadré en d'autres termes
d'accorder du temps de santé prévention
Adam les accords des salariés et faire
venir et faire venir les préventions aux
femmes donc soit on accorde une journée
soit on prend les rendez-vous parfois
les femmes ne veulent pas c'est pas
toujours si simple soit on fait venir
des gens sur le lieu de travail pour
faire des campagnes de vaccination par
exemple donc ça c'est un des points
qu'on a qu'on a mis en place au même
titre qu'il existe des référents à
égalité
il faudrait des référents prévention
voilà dans les entreprises donc on a
réussi à le faire pour l'égalité on
pourrait très bien le faire pour la
santé là on s'est focusé santé de la
femme certes vous vous doutez bien que
ce genre de propositions sont mixtes
bien sûr et bénéficie à tous
la prévention des récidives après une
longue maladie et après un congé
maternité compliqué est aussi une des
demandes que l'on a faite pour les
employeurs qu'il y ait quelque chose
vraiment de demander et de mis en place
dans ce cadre-là un retour de maternité
compliqué c'est compliqué et c'est sur
le dos de la femme voilà ça y est c'est
dans les statistiques et c'est même pas
une question d'opinion
afin d'inciter les employeurs à tenir
compte de la singularité féminine dans
la santé là il y a tout un levier qui
est complexe
un employeur qui parle de la santé des
femmes c'est tellement tabou que les
femmes qui prônent l'égalité ne veulent
parfois pas en entendre parler
et en même temps il le faut parce qu'il
y a une singularité de la femme dans la
santé et c'est tout cette ambiguïté
autour de la parole qu'on met dans les
entreprises avec le rôle de l'employeur
qui doit être travaillé discuter et pour
lequel on a un besoin vraiment de
coopération
en ce qui concerne des demandes que nous
avions en direction des pouvoirs publics
en pensant que c'était plutôt de l'ordre
des pouvoirs publics
il est nécessaire de mettre en place une
macroé une macro étude économique qui
montre le bénéfice des préventions au
sein de l'entreprise par rapport au fait
de pas le faire avec une entreprise
pilote
il y a un moment il faut quand même
regarder chose en face on va pas dans la
prévention quand on est employeur parce
qu'on a peur que ça coûte de l'argent
sauf qu'en fait le bénéfice il est réel
on le sait on en entend parler tout le
monde le dit sauf qu'il y a jamais eu
une Neptune économique qui la trouve
qu'il a trouvé il y a les moyens on a la
méthode on sait faire les études
macroéconomiques faut juste les mettre
en place une fois qu'on a montré que
c'est efficace et que c'est une économie
que pour l'entreprise déjà on a un
argument
qui contre la performance cet argument
qui est en remonté pour dire mais vous
vous trompez ensuite
clarifier le rôle et les missions de la
médecine du travail mériterait d'être
mis en place on sait qu'il y a des
guerres entre les entre les groupes de
médecine disons le clairement et il y a
notamment vous le savez les trois
rendez-vous de prévention qui ne sont
pas des consultations qui sont des
rendez-vous de prévention qui peuvent
donner lieu à une consultation quel est
le rôle de la médecine de travail dans
ces trois rendez-vous de prévention on
sait que pour l'instant les moyens pour
les mettre en oeuvre il y a déjà les
médecins sont déjà noyés les gens sur le
terrain sont déjà noyés quel est le rôle
de la médecine de la prévention
là-dessus la médecine du travail pardon
c'est un lapsus mais elles auraient son
jeu à jouer et puis on parle beaucoup de
la femme au travail on a oublié ici on y
a pensé les femmes qui ne travaillent
pas
les failles qui ne travaillent pas et
ben elles vont pas non plus dans la
santé elles y vont pas parce que du coup
elles peuvent pas y aller parce qu'en
général si elle travaille pas c'est
qu'elle s'occupe de leurs enfants et que
quand elles ont des rendez-vous
prévention elles n'y vont pas non plus
et donc il serait bien mais que la CAF
organise un système pour qu'elle puisse
aller faire leurs examens quand elles
doivent le faire
on les oublie souvent enfin
on demande que dans toutes les
politiques publiques
dans toutes les politiques de prévention
il y a un indicateur charge mentale
c'est-à-dire que quand on pense un
système de prévention quand on pense une
campagne de prévention quand on pense à
un dispositif de prévention on pense
l'indicateur charge mentale qu'est-ce
qu'on fait est-ce que ce que je propose
encore à lui en dire la charge mentale
ou pas et si oui
[Musique]